good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight not so long ago CNN president
Jeff Zucker gathered his minions on a
morning conference call and commanded
them to play up the ongoing impeachment
proceedings in the House of
Representatives impeachment impeachment
impeachment zuker squeaked nothing else
matters yell about impeachment until
your throat bleeds that's an order and
with that he slithered off back to his
lair deep beneath CNN center in the ice
caves and of course the minions obeyed
they were afraid not to obey but we
happen to disagree with Jeff Zucker now
if you're committed partisan as he is
impeachment often looks like the most
important story there is but if you're
not sometimes it seems like about the
fifth or sixth most important story
playing out in America right now there's
an awful lot else going on that's pretty
much how we've been covering the story
on this show which is to say not very
closely but tonight there's some actual
news to reports we want to take a moment
to assess what exactly is happening with
impeachment Speaker Nancy Pelosi has
announced that later this week the house
will hold a formal vote on procedures
that could lead to a formal impeachment
of the president at some point and what
exactly does that mean why is it
happening what will result from it all
of that unfortunately is still opaque
tonight it's still not exactly clear
what high-crime the president supposedly
committed there's some disagreement on
that question actually even on the left
so to solve the riddle we are taking you
tonight as we often do when cloudy
issues demand clarity to the Pride of
Yale Law School the Oracle of Newark the
single most famous bachelor vegan in the
United States Senate ladies and
gentlemen mr. Corey a Booker who read to
us tonight from his newly released
spoken word prose poem entitled politics
be damned
dim the lights be still and listen to
Corey politics be damned I have a job to
do which is to hold the executive
accountable politics be damned this is
our country this is our constitution
politics be damned right now this this
is a sad day a sad chapter in American
history politics be damned it's time to
do what is right and politics be damned
I just want to get the
I want to do my job politics be damned I
swore an oath to uphold and defend the
Constitution I need to do that politics
of this be damned so there you have it
politics be damned more in sorrow than
in anger Mistah this isn't about
politics cory booker says it's about
doing what's right as it always is in
washington and if you've got any doubt
about that he will say it again and
again and again and again until you are
too exhausted or hypnotized to protest
which ought to be a tip-off that in fact
the opposite is true actually this is
entirely about politics there is no real
crime behind the impeachment proceedings
instead the president's chief offense
appears to be disagreeing with policies
set by the bureaucratic state in
Washington how do we know that because
they've essentially admitted it over the
past two weeks the house has heard
testimony from a diplomat called Bill
Taylor and then an army lieutenant
colonel called Alexander vind Minh their
statements we are told will sink
president Trump maybe so what have they
said well to start both Taylor and VIN
Minh are intense Russia Hawks
both have testified that they want heavy
American aid to Ukraine because they
want to weaken Russia both have
emphasized that they don't want any
debate in the US about these policies
they've said that out loud in his
remarks bitumen said that he opposed
president Trump's phone call with the
president of Ukraine for this reason
quote I realized that if Ukraine pursued
an investigation into the Biden's and
burry smih it would likely be
interpreted as a partisan play which
would undoubtedly result in Ukraine
losing the bipartisan support
it is thus far maintained end quote and
the implication is that would be
unacceptable the Taylor said something
almost identical to that here it is
quote to restore Ukraine's independence
Russia must leave Ukraine this has been
and should continue to be a bipartisan
US foreign policy goal end quote so in
other words Washington may have two
parties but only one position on Ukraine
is allowed here
and Trump doesn't have it his phone call
was unacceptable because it might
prevent America from automatically
unthinkingly spending billions of
dollars over many years to prop up a
country that most Americans could not
find on a globe at gunpoint there's just
one problem with this array
voters disagree we know this because
when he ran three years ago President
Trump didn't hide how he felt about u.s.
foreign policy he told voters that
America was involved in too many
pointless Wars he criticized the then
President Obama for having bad relations
with Russia a Trump administration he
promised would pursue better relations
with Vladimir Putin now that may sound
shocking but in fact it was not an
unprecedented idea Obama ran on
something close to this in 2012 and the
public supported it then too he won but
now that same idea isn't simply
unpopular in Washington a ruling class
considers it illegal former CIA had John
Brennan put it this way on Twitter quote
as in previous times of national peril
we rely on our military diplomats
intelligence officials law enforcement
officers and other courageous Patriots
to protect our liberties freedom and
democracy may they stay resolute and
strong despite corrupt political
headwinds they face and quote got that
unelected bureaucrats uphold wait for it
democracy elected officials subvert
democracy in John Brennan's Orwellian
world the most pressing and imminent
threat to this Republic is voters